bibliothèques d'école. Pourquoi
pas, comme nous dit Anne-Louise
Desp
- Taisez-vous, s'il vous plaît.
- On va vous demander s'il vous
plisisisisisisisisisisisisisisi.
- Nous, on est à Montréal.
♪ L'amour est
un oiseau rebelle ♪
- Bonjour!
- Bonjour tout le monde!
de 6e année, pourquoi pas?
- Et puis à l'opéra
de Montréal...
- Surtout si ce sont les
artistes eux-mêmes qui répondent
JULIEN BILODEAU, compositeur
de musiqueiqiqiqique et d'opéra
- Voir un opéra, ça dure deux
heures. On se dit : Deux heures;
deux heures, à composer?
É ç ç ç ça peut prendre deux ans
dans mon studio avec mon piano,
mon crayon, puis mon papier. v a
rencontrer les chanteurs pourir.
- En direct de la bibliothèque
de l'école Saint-Donatininininis
d'élèves vivent une classe
de maître simultanément avec
le compositeur Julien Bilodeaute
Gagnon et Sophiet,t,t,t,
de l'Opéra de Montréal.isisisise
en réseau, 1eseseseses réparties
dans plusieurs régions, du Bas-
pouvoir apprendre à chanter.
- Si on faisait un exercice
avec
(longue inspiration)
- Bien respirer pour vibrer
à l'unisson.
- À go...
(Tous chantonnent.)ttttttttttttt
impressionnant parce que
ça prend du souffle, ça prend
la bonne intonation de voix,
ça prend du courage au
- Mais maintenant, là, que
je viens d'écouter, là,
je pense comme c'est magnifique,
- Genre, j'ai réalisé que c'est
pour tout le monde.
- "Ah oui, moi, j'aime tellemen.
Super... Puis maintenant, bien,
je trouve que l'opéra, c'est
comme une sorte d'histoire
qu'o- - - - - - - - - - - - - -é
leurs élèves.
MÉLANIE HARVAN, enseignante,
École Saint-Donat
la musique populaire,
ils aiment ces choses-là.
Ils vont décrocher assez vite!
Et au contraire, ils étaient
du souffle! Écoute la note!
Mais oh... Eille, rega
Puis là, ils essayaient
des choses. Ils se sont laissés
Là, tout à l'heure, on parlait
d'aller voir
Puis ils disaient : "Oui, oui,
on veut y aller."
scolaire qui a eu l'idée.
DOMI, , , , , , , Centre de
services scolaire de Montréal
- Je cherchais un moyen
différents quartiers d'entrer en
contact avec toute la
culturelle de Montréal.
- L'idée a grandi pour inclure
de partout au Québec.
Le programme d
à culture proposera donc
une rencontre par mois.
et Archives nationales du Québes
dans dans tous les milieux, là :
avoir des chanteurs, du cirque,
on va aussi voir des
scientifiques avec Exploramer
Les classes se connectent,
peuvent participer à toutes
les cabanes, découvrir plein
(applaudissements)
- Après avoir reconnu
leur bibliothèque, les élèves
ont eu droit à une rencontre
plus que virtuelle.
- C'est super touchant de voir
s'intéressent, parler de l'art
à la jeunesse, c'est comme semer
un jardin pour demain, t'sais!
je trouve que le projet
est extraordinaire!
- Après ça, ce qu'on a vécu
vraiment aller voir un opéra.
- Ce programme est soutenu
par le ministère de la Cultureee
et Archives du Québec.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
comme un merle ♪
♪ Ce qui vous ramène à do